with me until like later years
you know because i you know my last
anger management class was
i think it was 22 yeah last time
when you were 22 when you were 22. you
want to smile too um
so you know it's it's a
i you know there's just they just said a
lot of intriguing things one of the
biggest things that
you know that was said to me but i
didn't catch it until later
was when you know my anger management
teacher
we were talking i was like yeah i don't
have any i don't have any confidence
because of my
you know because of the way my step step
dad treated me
and he was like what he goes it has
nothing to do with him
because it's your confidence he goes
are you around him now or is he is he
here right now he's like
no he's like it's your confidence and i
didn't really get that at first
you know you know because i was just so
young and wild
and then um you know years later
it clicked with me i was like oh yeah i
was like so i don't need to make
anything
about him anymore where i was like i
controlled it yeah
yeah i was like i don't have to make
anything about him why do i need to like
have this energy of like hate you know
towards him you know what i mean you
know and and i and i thought
even deeper i was like you know there
were things that happened to him
when he was younger you know he was
doing what he knew
you know that was all he knew he was
just in that environment
right so i had to put all that into
consideration
to forgive this person and
forgive them with love because there's a
difference you know i think there's a
difference of
forgiving someone with you know
just saying oh i forgive you right
that's easy to say and walking away but
to forgive a person with love
means like damn this person that person
that is forgiving with love is
pretty in control of who they are yeah
you know what i mean you have this like
yeah when you when you hold when you
hold i feel like
when you hold a grudge towards someone
like that like when you have some stuff
that goes on
in your early life like that like abuse
from like a step
parent or something like that yeah and
you get older it's easy to use
them as an excuse for [ __ ] or like hold
like that that angst or hatred towards
them 100
but you're the one that suffers not them
yeah when you're when you feel like that
and you think like that you're
making yourself suffer oh yeah 100 and
once you can let go of that
then there's no more suffering you're
completely clear of it and you have no
you have no hard feelings or whatever
you almost want to thank them for
making you turn out the way you did oh
dude 100 like if he was here right now
i'd shake his hand
right you know just because it i mean
you know with all that i've learned and
i'm i'm so happy that
you know i've i've had these you know
certain people that i look up to and
admire
to help me find things for myself
you know what i mean um just just
finding that like in in the results i've
seen for
from it has been like wonderful for me
like i'm
like i walk through life a lot smoother
now you know most people like when i
tell people i went through
you know anger management most people
they don't even [ __ ] believe it
you know i go that's how hard i've
worked you know what i mean that's what
i
like or just i've learned so much
i've taken in so much because it's it's
yeah
like you know i see these people every
day
you know and i i get it you know
sometimes
you know within reason you know i see
these people wanting to
go after people online you know a person
does something
you know like one of the weirdest things
that i saw was uh
you guys are the actress of vanessa
hudgens yeah
so she posted a picture of her
at a at a cemetery and said it said my
happy place
right and someone got offended that she
said that
because she was at a cemetery they were
like oh my god i can't believe you're
doing this
yeah and it's like you i'm like you know
you you needed to do that you needed to
go
to her [ __ ] pages page
and say that like how are you okay
right you know that's like my first
thought to people like that are you okay
who hurt you what do you have going on
yeah what do you have going on yeah you
know what i mean because that's a that's
a it's a
you know to they don't understand yeah
yeah like you're making you're you're
making your
um you know
her picture is not about you right had
nothing to do with you has nothing to do
with you
but people do that people make these
other things about them
yeah because the most terrifying thing
to people
is to look within yeah people are scared
to do that
yeah [ __ ] scary but once you do it
you know [ __ ] you come out better
yeah anger management did you ever do
any writing
like was that was writing a process of
that you journal every day yeah
now when you like explain to me like
your process with journaling
versus like writing for comedy is there
is there
oh a difference between the two or is
there an overlap not even really it's
not even a difference
i mean the journal goes on stage pretty
much
really yeah you know because that's
where i make it
so honest and so clear to where i can
understand it
and when i have a clear view of it
what i say on stage like it's just like
you know i know what to say with it and
know how to make it funny because
i understand it um you know what i mean
like that's
that's the thing with it like i tell
jokes about
my abusive childhood you know because
and and it's and it's a tough joke
because
obviously when people hear the word
abuse they get uncomfortable
you know and i literally had to like
bomb that joke
a lot [ __ ] you know what i mean think
about it yeah yeah
and you know i really had to figure out
a way you know and one of the things
that i had to learn i was like don't say
this out of spite
because the crowd will get uncomfortable
because they can feel that
they'll know that you're not okay you
know what i mean so it's like
okay don't say this out of spite how do
i say this
out of like i'm having fun with it yeah
you know what i mean
and i lead it up you know to that i get
them
prepared for it you know what i mean but
in funny ways
and then i just [ __ ] drop it on them
and then and then it [ __ ]
they appreciate it because i made them
comfortable with it
you know what i mean i let them know
where i'm at
but i let them know where i'm at in such
a funny way in such a cool way too
yeah you know what i mean that and that
was all from like journaling about it
constantly just constantly writing about
you know what that you know childhood
was like
and what it where i'm at now you know
and when when i do that
and let them know where i'm at now and
how i am mentally
it's it sets them up like oh okay yeah
oh okay
i guess we can ride with this yeah you
know and in
in you know i mean
what that just doing that and what it's
done for me has made me realize so much
you know what i mean i think a lot about
like about yourself right
yeah yeah yeah everything you know
gosh and it's it's it's
you know it's hard to say you know not
even hard not
not hard to say um
it just does it's just not something
that clicks with people very easy
it's not an easy thing to just sit there
and tell someone like
hey i know that person wronged you but
don't make it about them
make it about you take control but
but i mean that's hard to get someone to
understand that
it's very hard you know so i i get it
sometimes you know like
i mean you know i want i was lashing out
at everybody but with violence
you know i always wanted to fight you
know because that's all i knew
all i knew was violence that's all i saw
in my house
so when i would go outside what was i
doing
i wanted you know violence so
you know yeah i do get it a lot of
people are doing what they know but a
lot of people need to realize
you know most of the time what someone
else is doing
has nothing to do with you i don't and
i don't take that abuse uh personal i
don't take it personal at all
why you know yeah he was doing what he
knew
like his like he he thinks he
you know was a great dad of course
that's not crazy you don't know why it's
not crazy because
his dad left him he didn't know his
father
you know what i mean so he was there in
my life
yeah he was there he was there that's a
big difference it's a big difference
from not being there yet exactly so
you know why would i think it's crazy
when when he would say
that he thinks he was a you know he
tried his best
he's right he tried his best and that
was what he
what he gave you know what i mean you
know and i still see him from time to
time
you know it was it was been it like i
haven't seen him in like four years
you know but i have a brother with
special needs so
my mom and uh him still have to see each
other like take him
you know the doctor's appointments or
you know whatever uh whatever they need
to do
to help him out and um you know a lot of
times
it you know it's there's not much
conversation there
and on my end i'm okay i'm like yeah
i'll talk to you
you know but i think you know
i don't i don't know as to why
it's not like you know i don't want to
talk to you
it's it's more like i don't know what to
say
you know i mean which is fine i get it
there's a lot of [ __ ]
you know i think and i think the cooler
story would be
you know to have a conversation with him
yeah why not
[ __ ] it who cares right we'll see where
it goes
yeah if it goes bad okay
i'm cool with me you know i love what
i'm doing mm-hmm
i'm having fun with life you know so